there are maybe I'm gonna guess ten
people maybe it's fewer in the world
that can really talk with any credence
about the shift from Steve Jobs to Tim
Cook the FT just announcing mr. Cook is
their Man of the Year we had the drama
you're in the moment with Bloomberg
Businessweek of when Tim Cook wrote an
essay for Josh Engle and our team your
thoughts on this transition of Apple
from mr. jobs to mr. cooks era well in a
sense he has certainly pulled it off or
financially the numbers market share
everything is great the bigger question
the longer-term question is new product
developments so well does your six plus
here you've got in the desk here does
that get it done I have to say they're
parts of Android that I prefer they'd be
quite analyst it's gotten it done for
the stock the stock is up 37% so far
this year guy do you think that Apple
can have as big a 2015 as it had you
know every year I say no and every year
I'm wrong so why would I be right this
year guys is Apple luxury brand or a
technology brand it's a luxury brand did
you know that when you were there no it
wasn't it was a luxury brand when I was
there back then when I was there Apple
supposed to die so it was a survival
brand right when did you see that shift
Oh with the iPhones with the I I
whatever's that that took it out of the
let's fight all the IBM PC clone windows
computers and it took it out of that
into a whole brave new world called
smartphones so you think that it was a
good idea to never let the price of the
iPhone be driven down with cheaper
models yes with hindsight though I would
have never predicted that I'm right with
you I wouldn't have thought so either
but it seems to be able to it within
this is the idea of ecosystem what does
how does Guy Kawasaki define ecosystem
I'll give you an example vehicle system
so until two weeks ago I was an Android
phone user and then I found out from a
social media service that they have one
particular application that is very
powerful for there's their platform and
without it you can't post as efficiently
and I need to post very efficiently so I
switch phones and literally switch
phones a couple hours after what
percentage of Android people would you
suggest are switching to Apple now in
the next
you're - you have a number you very low
okay I think it's very little switch
over both ways
tap it's going the other way on to
Android I think there's a growing well
you know if you're if you are believer
that it's a luxury brand you just stick
with it right it
the irony is with Macintosh one of the
big problems we have the Macintosh is
people just defaulted to Windows it was
an unthinking decision ya know they know
how it's true about iOS but the surprise
this year is iMac has done so well I got
we got one at home another one sitting
over there the computers had a pretty
good year right yes and the irony is the
phone is helping the computer as opposed
to vice versa see entropy and technology
choices once you're locked into a system
you stick around
yeah did you say entropy I did say entra
printed Greeley's thermodynamics on a
monday yeah sure isn't a second law
right that's great you're not just a
pretty face haha I'm done looking
forward to heteroskedastic you oh very
good
nerds just drop the mic Oh